[Music]
you are a Canadian so I have to ask you
your your your the Toronto Mayor Rob
Ford has been in the news yes all the
time he smokes crack a lot apparently
you don't even have to say allegedly
because he'll tell you oh yeah he seems
to be open about it yeah he's leaning
into the wave what's weird is like you
go to Toronto and it's like it's really
a beautiful city that is very well
running a lot better than a lot of non
mayor crack-smoking cities I've been to
in my life like Detroit is right across
the river and their mayor doesn't smoke
crack but maybe he should wait are you
saying that smoking crack may be
beneficial to serving as mayor I'm
saying you don't associate crack with
laziness at all I mean you do you don't
sleep much you don't eat much you get a
lot done you're a busybody on crack Rob
Ford's a fat crackhead which you'll see
that often I don't know how he's doing
that baby he's eating the crack I don't
know